she went through it with her mom
I'm going through it with my mum
the words of Maxine's daughter as her
mother struggles with Alzheimer's
it's scary to think that my children
will have to go through that potentially
with me as well
Katie doesn't know if she has the gene
putting her at risk of developing the
condition she thinks it's likely
new research suggesting hormone
replacement therapy known as HRT may
help prevent it has given her hope we're
losing people in our lives prematurely
because of this
um and you know she's well physically
and it's truly heartbreaking to see
to see the progression of the illness so
the difference that it would make I
think for for lots of people in my
position would just be to to keep their
loved ones in their lives for longer the
research still needs clinical trials but
could potentially help millions of women
almost two in three people with
Alzheimer's are women and one in Four
Women in the UK are carriers of the
apoe4 gene a strong risk factor for the
disease
Those Behind the study say the benefits
of HRT for women with the risky Gene
include better memory particularly if
used early the menopause itself
is is quite draining for brain function
and and the decline in estrogen which
happens during the menopause does seem
to really affect a number of
physiological processes in the brain and
I think you know once you can actually
get HRT in before those physiological
processes occur or before what we call
neuropathology which is the development
of of of the early signs of disease in
the brain once you can initiate HRT
before that starts I think HRT is much
more likely to be effective
dementia is a rapidly growing threat to
Future Health and Social care across the
world while this could help at the heart
of it is a desire to be with the people
we love for longer
Lisa Dowd Sky News